today
look
quick.
[Silence]
Why should
the
yesterday.
This
for us
many times before
is
of
what
people of
justice
knowledge are.
said
a
right said something
said
is that knowledge
think about the question is that
knowledge it's knowledge of what a sheer
said
but is it knowledge?
The answer is no.
Now if if you and and this is important
why because look how this is going to
play out.
I come and I say for instance to here is
here I say
he said the following
and counters and said
but I me said the following
right then comes into the discussion and
he says
but I im Ahmed Hel said this
And then brother Makoud comes and he
says but Abu Hanifh said this.
So now we've got four opinions. This is
hypothetical four opinions
and
all of us has presented
the statement of a respective imam of
the im of Islam.
So now where do we go from here?
How do we know which one is right and
which one is wrong? Who's correct?
If this is knowledge, then we've got a
big problem
because knowledge and the truth is only
one. There's no two truths.
There cannot be two opposing
statements and both of them be
fundamentally true.
The truth is one.
So these statements here if we do not
remedy this kind of situation what will
our discussion
devolve into eventually
it will devolve into
yeah but Abu Hanifh is the first one and
his med is the biggest.
Yeah, but I im Malik is Imm.
Yeah, but
refined Im Malik's Mab.
Yeah, but Imm Ahmed is more
knowledgeable in narration and he took
from all of them.
Yeah, that's true. But she did this. No,
but Malik did this. No, but she said
this. No, but I im Ahmed this. We're not
discussing knowledge anymore. The issue
is no longer at hand. Now what is at
hand is us either trying to raise up our
respective
person or put down the others.
There's no way we can come to an
agreement or a conclusion in this way.
This is not a discussion of knowledge.
Allah subhanahu wa'ta'ala warns us about
this.
He says subhanahua
[Silence]
He says, "Oh you who have believed,
obey Allah." Listen to the wording.
"Obey Allah
and obey his messenger
and the people of authority amongst
you."
And if you differ on anything,
the wording here
in.
[Silence]
He says, "And if you differ on anything
big or small, major or minor,
then refer it back to Allah and his
messenger."
This is knowledge. So Allah's wording
here is obey Allah. Listen how he
repeats the verb, right? The command.
Obey Allah and obey his messenger
and those in authority amongst you. He
doesn't repeat the word obey in the
third one because obedience of Allah and
his messenger is fundamental
and obedience of those of authority
is
subject to obedience to Allah and his
messenger. It's not the same level of
authority.
And if you differ on anything, then you
refer it back to Allah and his
messenger.
How do we refer it back to Allah? What's
meant by that? The Quran. How do we
refer it back to the messenger? What's
meant by that? His sunnah sallall.aii
wasallam. This is knowledge.
And so what is the definition of
knowledge? knowledge. Very simple
definition
is knowing the truth with evidence.
Or if we want to say what is knowledge
in the Quran and
knowledge. When Allah says knowledge in
the Quran, knowledge in the Sunnah, what
is meant by knowledge? It is knowing
Allah,
knowing his messenger,
knowing the religion or the legislation
of Islam with evidence.
This is the critical
differentiating
description here and that is it's not
just knowing Allah but knowing him with
evidence.
We all know that Allah is
we all know that right the allseeing he
sees all
what's the evidence for that
Allah says indeed Allah is the all
hearing allseeing now this is knowledge
once I have this evidence now it is
knowledge in this issue I have knowledge
that's what knowledge is
without evidence this is not knowledge
now back to our original example
we have
he said we have Malik said we have Abu
Hanifh said we have Ahmed said this is
knowledge of what they said
But why they said it that is what is
knowledge
and these things knowing the mahib and
knowing the opinions and the of the
scholars this is something that runs in
the same vein as knowledge but it on its
own alone is not knowledge.
So when we differ,
if we are differing
in this way,
this she said this, this said that, this
is not knowledge and this is not an
evidence in front of Allah and this is
not an argument in front of Allah.
That's why Allah set it up in the
following way. Obey Allah and obey his
messenger.
What if I don't know what Allah said on
this particular issue? I don't know what
his messenger said on this particular
issue. And those in authority amongst
you, who are those in authority amongst
us? the people of knowledge. In this
example,
the the companions
understood this statement,
those of authority amongst you as being
two types.
Remember we mentioned this before. There
are the the imam I im of the book, Imam
of the iron, Imam of the of knowledge
of the pen, imam of the sword. These are
the two types of imams. those who have
physical authority and those who have
legislative authority. Knowledge, the
people of knowledge and the people who
rule over us, those in authority.
And so who are those in authority in a
discussion of knowledge? The scholars.
Those who know the evidence for the
issue at hand. That is the person of
knowledge.
Right? Otherwise, we cannot ever get
anywhere with this. She said, "No, this
Shia said," right? And we see this a
lot. You see this often where, for
instance, we'll have a narration or a
verse or an issue and someone will go
and look on the internet and come back
and say, "Well, this Shia said this and
this Shia said that and this Shia said."
This is not evidence. This is not
knowledge. This in itself is not
inherent evidence.
Right? Now, what happens if we're in a
position where we don't know?
Allah says,
ask the people of knowledge if you do
not know.
And so the way that it was always to be
set up is that essentially the Muslim
reads the Quran. Essentially the Muslim
reads the Sunnah of the prophet
sallall.aii wasallam. Every individual
Muslim is acquainted with the Quran and
Sunnah as much as he is able to.
But each group,
each community,
they are to have people of knowledge
amongst them.
And when something occurs or some
difference or some issue arises, they
refer to that person of knowledge. They
don't refer to a random book. They don't
refer to this she said this or this sheh
said that. They refer to the physical
person of knowledge amongst them. and he
guides them through the issue. Right?
This is how it is to be set up. And if
we do this, what happens? We start to
become a collective. We now start to
become united
upon knowledge
and united around the people of
knowledge and the people of authority
amongst us. Right? This is how each
community is to function. Unfortunately,
what we see a lot of today is each
person is running off looking and
reading their own thing and each person
has their own way and following their
own thing. And this was never meant to
be in this way. There's no way to unite
if each person is his own imam and each
person is his own person of knowledge
and each person is his own scholar and
whenever something comes up I'm just
going to read a little article about it
or I'm going to read a few issues about
it and then run with it. That can't work
that way. There are many of us here,
most of us actually and every one of us
is
probably an expert in something. We have
mashallah community of professionals,
educated professionals. We have doctors,
we have engineers, we have architects,
we have software engineers right here
sitting right now with us. Right? All of
you are professional in some capacity in
some field.
You know from your own experiences
the difference between
reading an article or a paragraph on
something and
having intimate knowledge
of the inner workings of that particular
field. Correct? for instance, I
could take one verse or one narration
from the the Sunnah, right? And I could
say this is what this is supposed to be.
However, expertise comes into play when
a person has thousands of narrations,
all of the verses of the Quran,
decades of knowledge and research, and
now they understand the whole picture,
how this one narration or this one verse
fits in to the bigger, greater picture.
Correct?
There's a difference between a person
who can do an oil change on his own car,
right? And a person who understands
exactly
what this oil does, where it goes into,
where it's coming out of, what , you
know, look at the oil that's coming out
and can diagnose the the vehicle, listen
to something and hear a clicking and
know that this is a big deal or a little
deal, right? The average person can say
have some pain or some issue and
write it off as XYZ, but a doctor will
know that this this is actually
indicative of this over here. Right? If
you were to look up right now on on the
internet,
I have pain
in this part of my body. What does it
mean? It'll give you a hundred different
things that this pain could be right
now. Would any person with their right
in their right mind who takes their
health seriously look at that and say,
"Well, you know, it's a difference of
opinion. So,
this pain, you know, some some doctors
say that this pain could be cancer and
other doctors say that it's just gas and
others say that it's a heart attack.
I gas better. So, I'm going to go
with that. It's just gas. What do you
think of that? Huh?
Yeah, because it's a difference of
opinion, right? It's a difference of
opinion,
right? I have this headache. I looked it
up and some say that it could be a tumor
and some say that it could be a migraine
and some say that I just need sleep. ,
I don't the first two, so I'm going
to go with the last one. That one fits
best into my lifestyle,
right?
Or if a person was diagnosed with an
issue, a serious problem, would they
just go do a quick Google search and
then say, "Well, yes, I do have this
disease here." But, , what I read is
that, you know, you could just eat the
following foods and stay away from this
and it should resolve itself. So,
inshallah, I'll just go with that.
Right? Nobody te takes knowledge
seriously would do that because one
individual piece of knowledge has to fit
with the bigger picture. That's number
one. Number two,
if you take something seriously, you
understand that the truth could be
lethal, the truth could be deadly,
right? If this is in fact cancer and not
just bloating from, you know, tacos that
that you had a couple days before, then
your life could be at risk. And it's
not, well, I'm just making it and you
know,
Allah knows my intention and my
intention is good. So that's why I went
with the gas and not the cancer. So
inshallah it'll work out because I have
good intentions.
That's not how it works. It either is or
isn't something. And exactly the same
thing with the Quran and Sunnah. When
you meet Allah, it's either right or
it's wrong.
Right? Good intentions alone are not
going to deliver you from that
situation.
The scholars, the
and the companions,
they gave a really good example of true
knowledge.
They said a master
in knowledge and in the science of
hadith. They were speaking in the scope
of the science of hadith that you could
one a great scholar alkari Muslim
Abu Dani
Abu Zi
Abu Hatimi these other major scholars
of hadith they can hear a narration
and decide this narration is
correct in authentic or inauthentic.
And their students asked them, "How
could you know? I mean, to me, it looks
this. How can you know that so
immediately?"
And they said, "This is a goldsmith
asking a goldsmith how he knows if it's
real gold or fake gold." Casar,
how does he know? How can how can a
goldsmith as soon as he picks something
up he says this is not real gold right
this is goldplated this is not it looks
real to me how can you how can you know
that tell me how you know how can I
explain that to you this is something
that comes with years of experience
years of of of research until you
develop almost a feeling until you can
almost see the colors All right. This is
the point with respect to knowledge.
Now, to to end inshallah and we will
continue tomorrow inshallah with the
remaining
aspects of the pillars of fasting.
to end. Yesterday we left on a note and
that was we all know
that urine or that feces for instance is
filthy is negous right and we all know
that if you pray with that on your
person or on your body that this would
invalidate your prayer. We all know
that. Is there anyone who has ever
doubted that feces is filthy? None
amongst us that has ever doubted that.
However, what's the evidence for that?
Right? This is the difference between
knowledge and
you know general knowledge. This is
the difference and there are evidences
for that obviously. But the point is is
that this is the difference between a
person of knowledge and a person who has
you know facts that they have
accumulated over time. Right? And this
is why it is so critical that we always
always always
refer to the scholars in everything.
And when a scholar tells us something,
we trust them and we
and we stick to their directives and
their direction. And this is what will
keep the ummah united number one. And
number two, this is what will keep the
ummah on the path because we know that
when will the ummah start to go off the
path? The prophet tells us when will
that be?
When will that be? When the when the
starts to stray from the path.
No, the will start to stray from the
path when the people of knowledge die.
Isn't that what the prophet told us?
He said, "Allah does not take back
knowledge by extracting it from the
hearts of men.
Rather, he takes it back from a people
by the death of the scholars.
And the scholars will continue to die
and be more and more scarce and sparse
and more and more uncommon until there
is no more scholars left in a community
in a country in a state in an area.
And then when there is no scholar left
that there's a void, there's a vacuum.
Now who fills it? The impostors.
the R and J.
He said the ignorant leaders, they talk
people of knowledge. They dress
people of knowledge, but they're
not people of knowledge. And the problem
with that is that even they are
convinced that they are people of
knowledge. They've deluded themselves
even. And so then what happens? They
will be asked and they will speak
without knowledge and they will go
astray and take everyone astray with
them.
Now, we went a little bit over time
today, but it's okay. You know, whoever
needs to leave can leave, but during
Ramadan, it's it's good to have a few
extra words here on these topics. We'll
pick this up inshallah tomorrow.
sallallahu alaihi wasallam.
Make sure that you prepare yourself in
your mind
what your reaction is going to be today
at Jum or today in general with respect
to the fundraising for the academy for
the
everyone has to
decide to do something right. If if
everyone that comes to Jum were to
pledge just $100,
we would be in good shape at least. And
every one of us can spare that.
Oh yeah.